ai and machine learning sort of
technology has really uh
has the potential to make a very big
difference in this whole area and i sort
of think of this in terms of
three dimensions in which
machine learning technologies can really
make a difference one in sort of
expanding uh
the boundary of what is today possible
right so of course even in structure
prediction it was possible to find the
structure of proteins but it took a lot
of time and only very few organizations
had the capacity to to do it so by using
this technology we can now expand uh
what could be done uh secondly we
accelerate we can accelerate this
process because computational structure
prediction i mean uh the structures that
we have shared
with the database the researchers don't
have to wait for years on end to wait
for a structure they can just download
it in a matter of seconds and then
finally we have made this technology
accessible to people and scientists who
didn't have access to
these very expensive machines
to get
structures for the proteins that they
were interested in
so these are the sort of three ways i
think
a and machine learning can make a big
difference